you can measure the strength of a brand
based on how much more it can charge for
a commoditized good so for example if
there's a white T-shirt like this or
gray t-shirt like this and then this had
Louis Vuitton on it it would be
significantly more expensive if it's the
difference between the commoditized
price that anyone can purchase the same
good for and what someone else can
charge for is how you can measure the
strength of a brand and so when we're
thinking about our own Brands to see how
strong it really is how much more could
you raise your price without affecting
the demand that will be your answer for
how much you need to reinvest in the
brand itself